we are finally into projectile motion so
pretty exciting today it's a great
that's great little fun subtopic I guess
before we actually get started on any of
them else you need to know what this is
talking about and you guys know how much
I'm into languages so we're going to try
and address what the topic is first by
thinking about what what this thing is
talking about so it is to not
projectiles are projectiles are objects
that are you know given some kind of
initial force right so for example fired
out of a cabinet or thrown from an arm
okay so that's why you get these kinds
of develops they come up quite often and
importantly they're only under the force
of gravity so you know we're not
worrying about air resistance we're not
worrying about like spitting objects
that affect their their motion gravity
is the only thing that's going to act to
change the object's velocity so this is
something about acceleration okay so
we'll just go put here no air resistance
now depending on the object that you're
talking about it I'd be gets thrown or
gets fired but the general word that we
talked about like regardless of what
like it was a pike or something like
that with no description they would say
it's being projected that's where the
word projectile comes from okay
now projected is a lovely word it's a
really really wonderful word because it
is that wonderful combination of a
prefix and a suffix you prove together
and we actually use this suffix despite
here we use it for all kinds of other
words that we know about come on give me
a give me a healthier okay so say yeah
okay okay so you are you're giving me
with the same prefix give me some what
you to start differently but any the
same all right ok subjected what I can
say if you I'm gonna use these all those
verbs
okay how about subject when you get an
immunization the way you get that is you
get it injected
if a pilot was to get out of their play
they eject
if you if someone gives something to you
and then you give it straight back you
reject it right now a lot of the things
these are wonderful words right and you
can take object and all that kind of
thing just think about this okay when
you um when you eject something when you
inject something you take something you
you put it into something else right put
it in when you eject something you're
something's already in there and you're
taking it out when you reject something
you'll take something you're putting it
back and when you subject something like
if if one country subjects another one
what's it doing it's putting it it's
pretty it down myself
okay so project means you're putting
something where we've already got out
we've got out I don't think I have up
right see boom where do we get the web
pro from this needs forward right like
progress okay so this is really about
throwing forward well if you're throw so
what do you mean by backwards right if
you if you're doing that yes but that
means like that's the forward right like
that's your new forward okay so it's
always your city in a particular
direction so anyhow you couldn't ask for
a better word really in terms of all
these different things yeah we're
talking about when we say forward right
we generally mean up and away right good
morning so we need a picture here let's
draw a set of axes but as soon as we
think about what this is going to look
like and how are we going to represent
it visually we encounter a little bit of
a problem namely that when we've been
dealing aggression before um and we draw
it ourselves like a set of axes like
these what have each man sees being
indicated yeah time and displacement
right boy time displacement makes sense
because you're only thinking acumen
displacement along a single axis right
so we would have said okay
he's your x axis we want ten
read it out that it was really cool but
we said it kind of makes more sense for
this to be time passes your bless you
independent variable and this is
displacement which depends on time so
that's why we said let's oriental
vertically however if I take an object
right and I'm now throwing it through
the air shouldn't have caught it in my
left hand that was fun and it's it's
going up and down right but it's also
going like left right or or across
backwards that kind of thing right then
I kind of have two axes and I want to
use both of them to represent rather
than a special change and a
chronological change I kind of want to
use both of these for spatial change and
so that's exactly what I'm going to do
I'm going to happily return X so being
backwards horizontal orientation and I'm
gonna make this one y so I've got
horizontal and vertical changes now if I
throw an object through the air it
traces a path we'll talk a bit more
about this shape in what we'll see if we
get to it this lesson module concludes
after all when you have a look at this
though remember how we said oh really
nice before when we had time and X
displacement because you can look at
every point on there and it represents a
different time now I can't put another
axis on my piece of paper because all my
whiteboard because I really has the
students if I wanted to have an extra
dimension then kind of have to like come
come out of the board or I'd have to try
and draw it in an awkward way so I don't
really want to do that I want to kind of
avoid that however this is still a
passage of time you noticed this like
the object starts somewhere after some
number of seconds minutes it gets to
here and then it gets to here so time is
kind of hiding behind the X and the y
changes that there are it's kind of like
this third thing that's being measured
on the side of X&Y a third thing it's
being measured along the x and y we have
a name for this we call it a parameter
right so for example if I picked a point
right obviously it's got an X and a
y-coordinate okay but the X and the y
coordinate
each one of them independently relies on
T okay so even though I don't have an
explicit time axis I'm going to define T
and as my parameter in the same way that
good morning on the unit circle I
defined my angle as the parameter and
the parabola do you remember what I
define as the parameter on the frontal I
defined the gradient at 80 points okay
because the gradient made sense on a
circle you can define any planet circle
given angle okay you can define it
uniquely on the parabola you can define
any point on that parabola based on its
gradient you can define it uniquely
right there's only a single point on any
parabola where the gradient is saying
one right and there will be a single
point where it's zero and a single point
where it's negative 500 whatever when
you have a look at this there is only a
single point along this curve when is a
particular time so time makes sense
good morning as a parameter okay all
right so faster good you may like to
also add on to your diagram there are
essentially a project doesn't object
that's been thrown or fired right and so
we've been comparing to all these words
can we talk about changing the suffix
that gives you all these different
things if you change it in a different
way which is very very different very
very very different projecting is kind
of the opposite of propelling right so
case when I are losing to the subject
before and now some people said Oh
rocket rockets missiles planes but
anything that has some kind of
propulsion right there's going to keep
on moving not just under the force of
gravity but under the flapping of its
wheeze or the driving of its engine
right those objects are propelled not
projected okay so therefore order a
diagram here right at the starting point
you're something very awful at the
beginning I want you drawing an error in
the indicates kind of it will basically
a tangent line okay that's the initial
force that gets provided
and that's it that's all that makes this
thing move the rest of it that changes
the motions is gravity that's what
brings it back to earth and it's like
any fast I'm going slower under any
other influence okay all right so this
looks good now how do you look at this
diagram right we've got X's and Y's now
starts moving on these two axes of
motion so this complicates things right
because before all I needed to worry
about was three quantities X next time
and Excel ago right
what's your displacement velocity and
acceleration in straight-line motion
there's only one kind of displacement or
velocity or acceleration because you
only have a single axis of motion this
is no longer the case is it right
so alongside worrying about next X dot
and X double dot I'm going to have to
worry about not just this horizontal
change but the vertical change as well
right so along with these guys you're
going to get why why don't you and y
double dot okay so every time you think
of that projectile motion you will get
six equations of motion okay six
equations we're going to work with all
of these but you need to think about
them very carefully you want to
distinguish between horizontally and
vertically
and also can I just start make a big
statement as you write these equations
and because you've got so many flying
around I can't stress enough right
please don't just look up for a second
probably for most of this when you write
x dot you probably just do literally
bits you write your X and then you just
place a dog right I'm going to strongly
encourage you not to do that
I greatly encourage you to color in a
dot you wouldn't believe the number of
times students have written the
expression and they've just they just
put the dot there and because you're in
a hurry and you've got a million
equations flying around you just don't
see the dot there where you think
they're two or it's just really silly
how many students make errors just from
miss reading their handwriting okay so
make your dots nice and big and obvious